people are very conflicted about what
what prisons are for there are they to
punish people and make them have the
most horrible awful life possible or are
they to open up other chances for them
or possibly a combo now we would all
agree that some people really need to be
in there because they are a danger to
some other people if running around
outside and quite frequently a danger to
themselves it's also quite true that
some of them probably don't belong in
prisons at all they belong in in
institutions that would do something
about their mental challenges that
they're having prison systems in hag
zine which is a revisit in prose novel
form of shakespeare's played The Tempest
it's kind of inevitable that you would
be writing about prisons because there
are so many of them in the play so
revisiting the play involves writing
about imprisonment coercion of various
kinds and everybody in that play is is
imprisoned constrained unfree in some
way for some part of the play except
possibly Miranda who although she's on
an island she can't get off of doesn't
know anything better so doesn't feel
that she's imprisoned I might point out
that on this island there's no butter
they towed it up the things they had to
eat and they were fairly limited so you
can see why Prospero might want to get
back to the land his hometown simply to
have something better to eat but that's
an aside so so I did look at prisons and
I was involved earlier in a protest in
Canada
against the closing of prison firms
where people had been learning to
interact with and care for beings other
than themselves namely animals which is
which can be very therapeutic
over the years prisons have gone through
many forms you know were they to put
your political enemies in so you could
rent some them later were they to put
criminals in in order to punish them
were they debtors prisons where you
oddly put people in who couldn't pay
their debts thus making it impossible
for them to pay their debts their
relatives would usually have to bail
them out if they had any relatives then
in the nineteenth century a very
reforming age we got the idea that that
prisons should be improving that people
should be improved by them that they
should learn skills that would be useful
to them later on instead of prisons they
got called Penitentiary's and then some
of them got called reformatories so
you're going to reform people and in
nineteenth-century
prison systems in North America which I
wrote about quite them I read about
quite a lot to write my novel alias
grace which concerns a famous real-life
murder case they taught illiterate
people to read and write so that they
could read the Bible so they were very
instructional in that way where we are
now is we don't know and it doesn't make
sense to talk about the prison system so
which which prison where how does it see
itself what is it being used for and who
is sent there I was at Bard College a
little while ago and they do run ain't
college degree system in an adjacent
prison and you can get your degree and
in fact a couple of people graduated
that
because I was there for graduation and
as for teaching Shakespeare in prisons
that has gone on more than you might
think there's a very good book called
Shakespeare saved my life which is about
a female college professor who went into
a maximum-security all-male prison and
taught Shakespeare she had to sit in an
aisle to do it and the people learning
were in these little cubicles but she
said that she got better papers from
them than she got from her college
students because those people had been
there and done that
you know they had they had assassinated
Duncan those were the kinds of crimes
they were in for so they were able to
speak from personal experience about
Shakespeare's accuracy and portraying
the emotions you know how you feel is
this a dagger that I see before me
apparently you you do except these days
that's a gun so that kind of thing there
is a book by an Italian man who did
teach The Tempest and a prison found it
transformative for the people in it he
actually put it on and when he came out
he wrote this book about it and is now
currently building out the program of
putting on Shakespeare and in prisons it
has been it has been done and if it
hadn't been done I wouldn't have been
able to write the book the way I did
because I didn't want it to be
completely implausible you know
something in it that would never happen
it has happened and it does happen and
from what I hear about it it shouldn't
happen more because a lot of the people
who were in prison are in there because
they have not had the advantage of an
educational system they have not been
able to learn usable skills
and skills that they can actually get a
job with and therefore they have drifted
not all of them but a lot of them they
get absorbed into these other ways of
making money the other thing that
literacy and literature do particularly
what we call literary fiction or plays
like Shakespeare's you learn empathy
because you learn what it is like to be
another person you learn what is like to
feel the emotions of another person and
if you have been in a very constricted
sort of life in which your main idea has
been just to keep yourself alive and and
keep going you often just don't think of
what you're doing to other people and
how they might feel
you